Oh
leaves changing I mean it's just
beautiful I've lived here all my life
and I just get this thrill when I see
them you see the green trees all summer
you get kind of used to that and all of
a sudden you cos burst of color it's
just really exciting to see those leaves
changing here some color coming up that
pretty yes so you gotta practice you're
doing and eyeing obviously are you
supposed to be excited not in pain yeah
this is where the covers are supposed to
be so this is where you come to New in
you have you know Mount Rushmore you
have washington DC you have the redwoods
in California in New England it's the
trees in the fall that's why it's here
I mean you can see a tree anywhere you
can go outside an apartment building and
see a tree but I think there's something
special about being where America began
and to have the foliage in this kind of
a setting i think is really special see
we reorder the sunlight to hit it
purposely for you yeah I think it's
something you've always heard about
you've always wanted to see it it's
awesome the colors have been beautiful
the scenery the the brisk October air
everything has been so perfect for our
trip here on someone I work with came
last year and she was saying it's
absolutely amazing site you must go so
that's why I'm prejudiced i guess but i
don't think there's any place else in
the world that has the variety and the
color that we have a lot of places have
just the yellow or just the orange but
we have a little bit of everything all
kind of mixed in together with many
different species of trees
well we get more gold and green we don't
get the Reds because we don't get so
many maples aces so now this is
different totally different
the option to come up here is a chance
to relax refresh and it's very rewarding
and peaceful to see the colors for me I
think what comes to mind is a beautiful
painting something on canvas something
that you've seen and admired and to be
here and being right in the middle of it
all it is just fantastic well I guess
the best question in regards to foliage
is some it will raise your hand and say
gee did you did you purposely plant
these trees like this and no we didn't
that's nature that's what nature does
it's nature's colors it just happens
that way but you know the gentleman that
asked it didn't really believe me and
well I can take credit for it I guess
that's okay with me you can't predict
nature so I guess that's kind of the
most difficult thing is when you're
planning a tour how do you guarantee
that you're going to see color you can't
nothing the contrast when you get the
right in the gold against the green
rather than too much red I'm happy what
I'm saying well there's the is the leaf
tour when you come by and you know you
just see the green leaves there's the
foliage tour when the colors of chain
are changing and it's just beautiful and
then there's the twig tour when you're
too late the leaves are gone
Tommy it's beautiful absolutely but just
put you in a different mood to clears
your mind get you back to nature just
makes you feel really good